Salut à tous C'est pêcheurs de trésors.
Et non on ne commence pas par la fin
On est arrivé sur un spot
qui avait déjà été fait
visiblement par de très bons pêcheurs
à l'aimant
Félicitations à tous.
Par contre,
ils auraient dû ramasser la ferraille.
C'est dur à ramasser ici
Et peut être qu'ils ont laissé le temps
et qu'ils viendront après.
On ne va pas critiquer
parce que c'est compliqué.
Aujourd'hui, on n'est pas tous seuls
On est avec Wim qui est encore là
et avec Danny.
Encore une fois, tous les réseaux de Wim,
sont en description
Mais vous commencez à le connaître.
Ça fait un moment qu'on pêche avec lui
et regardez, c'est encore plein d'objets.
Donc là, on a Dany
qui nous a fait du Happy Gaz
Gaz hilarant
Tu es heureux ?
Tu es content de ton gaz ?
Et bien sûr nous sommes en compagnie de Rasta.
Est ce qu'on va faire qu'on
va attaquer la pêche tout de suite à.
C'est parti
Vous êtes prêts les gars ?
(Pieds sur la corde de Quentin)
Baptiste !
C'est pas moi
Ca va ?
Ca va bien merci
C'est pas vous sur Tiktok ? -Si si
Un scooter
Bien joué
C’est toujours bien de trouver des clefs
Ca vient aussi surement d'un scooter
Bien joué
Voyons voir ce qu'il
reste dans ce canal.
Monsieur si vous trouvez un trésor vous m’appelez
Ouais, on partage
j'ai quelque chose.
Un vélo
Ouais et un téléphone
Un téléphone rouge
Oh non, rasta, il est déjà sale.
La batterie a été enlevée
Ils ont pensé à l’enlever avant de le jeter
Ils ont pensé à l'environnement
Allez, un petit vélo.
Allé, ca vient
C'est lourd
Vas-y
Une moto
Il est joli.
Il y a aussi un vélo
Monsieur, vous allez tout laisser là ?
Non, on ramasse ce qu'on peut.
Menteur
On vend au ferrailleur,
regarde les vidéos.
C'est joli.
Sympa.
OK. Sympa la Yamaha
Un scooter de plus.
Juste le cadre mais c'est pas mal
Bien joué Danny les muscles !
ça c’est pas du fer
C’est pas du plastique c’est en métal
Aluminium ?
Oui aluminium
Et là, j'ai quelque chose.
Oh une munition
Elle est vide
Calibre douze vide.
Et ça, surtout une boîte de filtres
On va l'ouvrir quand même.
Un bout de radiateur
Un autre protoxyde d'azote
Alors Quentin, on veut trouver quoi aujourd'hui ?
Des armes.
Je suis d'accord
Il peut y avoir des bijoux, des coffres forts
Allez, on a quelque chose
Un cadre de vélo
un tabouret.
Bien joué.
Encore du protoxyde.
La même
De l’argent !
Une caisse de monnaie
J'ai une caisse
Elle est fermée
Jolie couleur !
On l'ouvre ?
Il y a une pièce
Il y avait une pièce
La clef de la boîte peut-être
Non rien
Mais c’est bien quand même !
Bon début
On va tous venir pêcher ici
C'est bon.
J'ai eu peur.
J'ai cru que c'était l'échelle
J’ai vu un pistolet !
Il y avait un pistolet
Un pistolet ici !
J'ai vu un pistolet.
Est-ce qu’il faut que je plonge ????
Allez,
Quentin tu dois le retrouver
Ouais je dois le retrouver
On doit le retrouver
Non...
J’attends une dernière remontée ensuite je viens lancer à côté de toi
Mais c’est à moi !!
Oui oui bien sûr
Ah yes !!
Je pense que c’est un pistolet d’alarme
Cool !
Bien !!
Incroyable mec !
Bon début
Bien joué !
Bon début Quentin
Bravo Quentin
Il y a des inscriptions ?
Une caisse et un pistolet !
Tout ce dont tu as besoin
Fabriqué en Italie
Ok c’est pas si loin
Mini gap
mini gap.
Je l’aime bien
Fais voir
Belle découverte
Cool
Léger ?
Non pas léger
Ah il est lourd ?
Oui
Mais je pense que ce n’est pas du fer
C’est du Zamak
C’est pas du vrai acier
C’est pour ça qu’on voit qu’il est à blanc
Certains vrais pistolets sont aussi composés de plastique
Il a deux détentes ?
Non c’est une détente de sécurité
C’est super mec
C'est bien un pistolet d'alarme.
On le voit parce que là, c'est pas
de l’acier c'est du zamac
Le zamak est un alliage à base de zinc, auquel sont liés de l'aluminium, du magnésium et du cuivre. Il tire son nom de l'acronyme en allemand de chaque élément entrant dans sa composition
Joli joli.
Des bijoux !
Et une boîte
Oh le chien ! Il est mignon
C’est un pilulier je crois
C’est une jolie boîte
Rasta, arrête de faire la star !
Oh, des ciseaux, bien joué
Ils fonctionnent
Ouais
Un téléphone
Ouais, mais il retombe à chaque fois.
Attends il faut que j'y aille doucement.
Tu as encore un téléphone ? Oui
Tu as trop de la chance
Echo Memento
Je vais finir par me bloquer
OK, un pignon de vélo.
Enfin, j'ai enfin trouvé ma première arme
en compagnie des Hollandais
parce qu'à chaque fois c'est eux
qui trouvaient tout.
Donc je suis content, ça s'inverse.
C'est vrai
Quelque chose est en train d'arriver
On va voir ce que c'est
C'est incroyable ce tas et ça continue.
Une batterie,
On dirait une batterie de scooter ? Non,
Il y a un truc brillant
Oui c’est brillant ça
C'est une boucle d'oreille.
Donc il faut la garder.
C’est sûrement pas de l’or mais bon...
Il y a que l’anneau qui est magnétique
C'est pas aimanté en tous cas
Sympa
ça c’est un petit transformateur
Encore des bijoux
Oh, c'est plein de bijoux !
Regarde
Plein de bijoux
De différentes formes
Coincés par le metal
Celui-ci est uniquement magnétique sur cette partie
OK
C’est une belle découverte
Sympa. Belle trouvaille.
Et la chaîne est magnétique
Encore félicitations
Ces gars trouvent tout
Et moi je n’ai rien
C’est vrai !
Il y a Baptiste qui signe des dédicaces
Wim qui a un vélo
ouais,
Un autoradio, sympa
Et aussi un leurre de pêche
Oh non il y avait encore un téléphone
Il est au bord
Ah ouais.
Je vais essayer de le choper.
Ouais, une belle plaquette,
une clé aussi.
Tiens, elle est encore très bien.
On va essayer de sortir le téléphone.
Il est très peu aimanté on dirait
il est retombé, on le trouvera
peut être après
Ah non, il est là, j'avais même pas fait gaffe.
Tiens, je te l'offre
Merci
Oh non, protoxyde d'azote.
Je crois que c'est un porte monnaie ça
il me semble.
Regarde, avec une chaîne
Dites moi en commentaire, mais je suis pas
sûr
Il est vide
C'est un grelot de pêche.
Danny a trouvé une montre
Charente Maritime
C’est un département en France
Charente Maritime. Dédicace à Jade.
La montre est jolie
L'Île d'Oléron
C'est un endroit en France, c'est une souvenir
Une selle
Je suis coincé
On va essayer de là bas.
Je pense que c’est mort
On va essayer de là bas
Quentin a fait une bêtise,
il s'est accroché sur l'échelle.
Comme en Allemagne
Mais cette fois l'eau n'est pas froide
Elle est coincée
Il a fait une bêtise donc maintenant il doit décoincer son aimant
Il y a des choses ouais
Je vous vois souvent
Merci
Il y avait un abonné
Attends Quentin, il faut que j'enlève mon aimant.
Attends
un autoradio.
Tu pêche sur ma corde pendant quelle est bloquée.
Quelle idée de laisser ta corde là aussi.
L'échelle va jusqu'au fond.
C'est pas normal.
Bon, je vais tenter
Ouais, c'est bon.
Bien joué.
Je crois qu'on a une touche.
Une épée ?
Non
J'y ai cru
Dommage
La poussette
La poussette de Wim
C'est la corde de Quentin
qui était coincée.
On va voir si ça lui a permis
de pêcher quelque chose quand même.
À part le fameux tuyau
qui nous gêne depuis le début
et que je vais finir par réussir à sortir,
Voilà ce que t'as attrapé Quentin. C'était
vraiment pas une belle pêche.
Tout ça pour ça ?
Il faut que tu sépares les deux cordes.
Je vais continuer de pêcher avec le mien
On va essayer de tirer un peu loin.
Aimant lancé
Allez une autre trouvaille
l'île d'Ax
Et de l’autre côté il y a une autre couleur je crois
ça vient d’un autre département
Tu as plein de souvenirs de France
Charente Maritime aussi
Même endroit
Alors qu'est ce que j'ai ?
Oh oui, un leurre de pêche
Pour notre ami pêcheur
Il est un peu abimé mais bon.
On peut toujours l'utiliser.
Ouais, je pense.
Une sorte de filtre à gazole.
Un vélo et quelque chose d'autre
C'est un Scanner de magasin
Cool, c'est original
Une boucle d'oreille
Elle brille bien
Encore un vélo
Il se croit à Amsterdam c'est bon
Allez, on va continuer.
Encore un.
Tu connais la marque ?
Il ne reste plus rien !
Voilà, je me suis décalé.
Je suis toujours sous la passerelle
On va voir ce qu'on trouve
Il faut que tu viennes.
Il y a un endroit ou on peut être deux
c’est plein !
J'ai un gros truc
là, c'est rempli les gars.
J'ai encore un gros truc
Alors, qu'est ce que j'ai encore ?
Hop hop hop !
de la fonte,
il y a plein de trucs
Là c'est périeux alors je vais m'attacher à ce truc
en fer pour pêcher.
C'est tellement inaccessible
que ça n'a du pas être fait beaucoup
On va faire une boucle là.
OK, on a quelque chose
gaufrettes, cigarettes.
Encore quelque chose
de gros
Ca vient
Un vélo je dirais
Oui un vélo !
Il n'est pas vieux celui là
Dédicace aux abonnés
Je fais une dédicace
Vas y
Dédicace à vous Monsieur,
je vous aime.
Merci, merci.
J'ai quelque chose d'hyper lourd.
ça a lâché
Wow !
Ça c'est du.
C'est une bouteille de gaz ?
Je vais essayer de la décrocher de l'aimant
Sans la faire tomber dans l'eau.
C'est Pêcheur de Trésors ?
Oui
Tu as besoin d'aider ? J'arrive
qu'est ce qu'on a ?
Ces gros plots, il y en a plein
Ca fait chier ça.
Un lampadaire,
C'est les poteaux qu'il y a sur la route
Comment tu fais pour l'enlever du coup ?
Comment on enlève ?
Il faut que tu te mettes là haut
Dites salut à YouTube.
Abonnez vous
c'est le bordel.
C'est la sortie du collège.
OK, on sort pas mal de trucs.
ça va ?
Oui bien bien bien
Tu veux aller ici ?
Il y a un endroit derrière le poteau
Il faut des chaussures avec des crampons ici
Un téléphone
Un poteau et du protoxyde d'azote.
C'est votre enfant ?
Lui ?
Mais pas du tout ...
Si on l'a adopté
Non, ce n'est pas vrai
Est-ce qu'on peut prendre votre chien ?
Comment ça le prendre ? Non !
On le garde.
Il est croisé Akita Inu
C'est trop lourd ?
J'arrive
Un de plus
Un panneau.
Il n'y a pas de panneau.
Monsieur, ça fait quoi d'être connu ?
Rien
Un lampadaire
C'est une lampe halogène
Un vélo pour changer
Enfin ce qu'il en reste
Il ne reste rien
Attention
Oh merci
Un vélo et un panneau
Un panneau.
Je vais lancer de nouveau je crois
Fais tomber ton téléphone, on le repêche
Je ne garantis rien.
OK, peut être que j'ai un bout
Le vélo, ok.
super
Tu peux faire des roues arrière, tranquille
Ouais voilà
Super
Un boulot de canon
Ah non une boule de pétanque
Voilà donc le résultat de cette pêche
à l'aimant.
Bien sûr, en rajoutant de l'eau découverte
à celles qui ont déjà été faites par une équipe
qui est passée ici précédemment,
c'est totalement n'importe quoi.
En sachant surtout qu'il en reste
et qu'on n'a fait qu'un seul côté du pont aujourd'hui
Ce qu'on va faire,
c'est qu'on va ramener le maximum.
Mais bon, on est venus à cinq,
On n'a pas énormément
de place dans le camion
Aujourd'hui, on récupère donc le maximum
qu'on peut et dans tous les cas,
il y aura assurément une partie
deux à cet endroit tellement c'est dingue.
C'est magnifique
On est certain d'être passé à côté de dizaines
d'objets intéressants aujourd'hui.
Si c'est pas déjà le cas,
pensez à vous abonner pour être averti
lorsque la partie deux
sera publiée à cet endroit.
D'ici là portez vous bien
A la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle vidéo de pêche à l'aimant
Bravo
Bonnes suspensions